PlayStation got ahead of the usual leaks
that happen at the end of every month by
revealing the games coming to the
essential extra and premium tiers of its
PS plus servers during its recent state
of play for the month of March the
essential tier of PS plus the lineup
includes Minecraft dungeons Battlefield
2042 and code vein available for
subscribers on March 7th the PS5 and PS4
versions of Battlefield 2042 will be up
for grabs though the latest entry in
EA's long-running FPS series got off to
a rocky start when it launched in 2021
consistent updates have been rolled out
ever since that have improved to the
online experience including recently
adding a class system a previous series
staple that the game originally launched
without in favor of individual
Specialists with unique abilities akin
to Hero Shooters with Battlefield 2042
coming to PS plus you can expect an
increase in play accounts so it will be
a good time to give it a go Minecraft
dungeons is essentially Minecraft's
version of Diablo and it's pretty darn
Good played from an isometric
perspective Minecraft dungeons is all
about slashing your way through groups
of enemies in search of new loot
Minecraft dungeons really hits its
stride the more you play and is best
enjoyed with friends this is a great
family-friendly Cooperative game to play
with kids and it could help you scratch
that Diablo itch while waiting for
Diablo 4. if you're a fan of action RPGs
and haven't checked out codevane it's
certainly worth a look when it comes to
PlayStation Plus the Bandai Namco
published RPG takes cues from The Souls
like genre and has a flashy anime
aesthetic even though you can see the
Dark Souls influence while playing code
vein is more forgiving it has strong
combat cool environments and a lengthy
campaign that can be played Solo or with
a friend if you are subbed to either the
extra or premium tiers of PS plus not
only will those three games be available
to you but so will a bevy of other new
additions including Chia a game
launching the same day it comes to the
service Chia is an indie game that has
you take control of the title the
character as she explores New Caledonia
based on a real world cluster of islands
near Australia Chia not only has the
ability to Glide but also to inhabit a
variety of animals and objects in her
journey the game will be available
starting March 21st are the games coming
to the two more expensive tiers of PS
plus include ghostwire Tokyo Immortals
Phoenix Rising Rainbow Six extraction
and Uncharted Legacy of Thieves
collection expect more games being
announced for March for the servers in
the coming weeks as PlayStation has yet
to put up their own blog post about the
additions which is usually how it
announces the new lineups and remember
while games come and go from PS plus
extra and premium tiers based on
whatever contracts the Publishers
negotiate with Sony the essential games
will always be in your own game Library
as long as you're a subscriber the
monkey Showcase of the recent state of
play was rocksteady's long-awaited
Suicide Squad killed this league which
finally confirmed that the game would be
a live serves title akin to Marvel's
Avengers actually not just Akin an
almost identical replication of that
game's formula with battle passes for
character cosmetics and new playable
characters being added to the roster
down the line the developer also
confirmed that the game would require a
constant internet connection even when
players are playing by themselves
considering the long list of recent
shutdowns of live service titles which
includes the Avengers game the Warner
Brothers has pushed Rocksteady to
replicate many online are concerned that
the title is Dead on Arrival well ahead
of its May release can Rocksteady do
what Crystal Dynamics couldn't with a
less popular casting of playable
characters let us know what you think in
the comments below and we'll see you
here for more Gamespot news
[Music]